here in the GameSpot UK office we have a
new obsession Westworld we love the
concept
we love the violence we love Anthony
Hopkins but it's given Tam a deep
distrust in anything controlled by AI
No I trusted you Tam you just gotta hit
the stop button terms misplaced trust in
the offers coffee machine aside
Westworld got us thinking about all the
bastard evil robots we've seen across
films games and TV from conniving
ai-controlled freighter ships to goatee
sporting identical twin BOTS there have
been enough in fiction to legitimately
warrant us being worried about this
self-learning Dumais I called Arnold
that's beating real human players so
before Arnold becomes fully self-aware
here are 6 other robots we should have
known couldn't be trusted
okay so the Three Laws of Robotics by
Isaac Asimov exists as a safety measure
present in all robots just to ensure
that nothing happens to our beloved
mankind in case you're not familiar with
them these rules are pretty well regards
in the science fiction universe so you'd
think that would make our little robotic
helpers pretty reliable now well in
iRobot the mechanicals have been serving
humanity for some time and are present
in pretty much every walk of life every
home every business pretty much everyone
has some form of mechanical helper all
living peacefully in accordance to the
three rules now bending rules is one
thing we've all done that in one way or
another but creating brand-new ones
without consulting anyone that's a whole
different problem especially when those
rules involve enslaving all of humanity
the robot mastermind supercomputer Vicky
has decided to create the superseding
zeroth law a robot shall not harm
humanity and since apparently we're
recognized as being the biggest threat
to ourselves what with the global
warming and all the wars and the gun
crime wait we're pretty shitty really
the robots think it's best for us if
they just take all our freewill away and
leave the thinking stuff to the living
computers so next time your Roomba is
doing its rounds around the living room
just think it might be considering
enslaving you enslaving you to a life of
dust
SIMEX please zina Wheatley is an
intelligence dampening personality call
in other words he's an idiot designed to
turn others into idiots you may think
that GLaDOS is more deserving of being
on this list and given that she murdered
all the scientists our Aperture Science
and force you to go through lethal
physics-defying rat mazes you'd be
mostly right as you probably know from
having spent time on the Internet
there's nothing more deadly than an
out-of-control idiot really was
originally one of the numerous
personality calls attached to GLaDOS and
basically spent his entire existence
quote in poor to his back in operation
and freeze main character Chell from the
relaxation vault what starts off as a
partnership between shell and a
dim-witted but well-meaning AI quickly
becomes a fight for survival really
accidentally reactivates GLaDOS but
Chell manages to bring her down again
but drunk on his newfound power he
assumes the role of evil boss and runs
child through another series of deadly
tests naturally like most idiots that
get a bit too sure of themselves
everything backfires on him when Chell
teams up with GLaDOS Wheatley's ultimate
fate is to be blasted into space and
float around aimlessly for all of
eternity I am genuinely sorry the end oh
and while we're talking about shitty
videogame robots bastion sucks and is
for scrubs
originally Battlestar Galactica's Cylons
were created to do the grunt work that
we humans just didn't feel like doing
that was all going swimmingly until
someone had the bright idea to Dropbox
them a human consciousness naturally
resentment grew from the now completely
sentient workforce so the Cylons sort of
sparked a huge war killed a few billion
people then jettisoned off into space
and like good children of humanity were
neither seen nor heard from for forty
years or so in that time those sneaky
Cylons were up to something namely
figuring out how to look exactly like
human beings making their mechanical
espionage all the sneakier seeing as
Cylons have a certain affinity with
network technology you'd think that
humans would be a little wary of
machines not like the way that my mom is
afraid of the microwave but in like her
maybe we shouldn't network all of our
nuclear weapons capable of straight-up
destroying the Twelve Colonies into one
easily hackable defense system kind of
way
so many robots or computer systems that
end up trying to destroy humanity who
originally intended to either defend or
assist us you put so much trust in
Skynet but boy we burn for that the
Terminator franchise gave us Skynet a
revolution system created by Cyberdyne
systems and some leading light of
humanity had the bright idea to give a
command over all computerized military
systems great just was great so after
the world was bathed in a fire of
thousand nukes Skynet then saw fit to
enslave the surviving members of
humanity to build their automatic robot
factories the decades to come see the
surviving members of the human race
track down by Skynet to fulfill the
Mandate of its original coding which
brings us to the first terminator
here we see the t1000 hunting down Sarah
Connor before she could give birth to
the leader of the human resistance in
the future after spending days on the
run for the mechanized seemingly
invincible killing machine it's not
surprising that you found it rather hard
to trust the same mechanized seemingly
invincible killing machine when it
returns a burst trap hospital in
Terminator 2 the whole Skynet thing
should really just be one big lesson
about trusting too easily that I'm not
giving all your nukes to appalling
programs AI without an off switch
admittedly the least trustworthy
cottoned ex machina is probably Nathan
Bateman played by Oscar Isaac I mean he
may seem like an intelligent future is
trying to advance science and thus the
human race but that's just a cover for
being a mega bad dude you just need to
look past a glorious beard and the sweet
dance moves to see it but it's Ava the
sympathetic AI Bateman has built an his
experimenting on that delivers the most
crushing betrayal Bateman has created
Ava based on Caleb's desire and over the
course of the movie Ava and Caleb bond
and as the connection deepens Ava
reveals that she dreams of freedom with
Caleb and the two conspired to escape
and live happily ever after
of course Bateman learns of the plan and
he tries to stop him and in a final
confrontation where Machine rebels
against man Ava plunges a knife into
Bateman staining his pearlescent white
shirt with crimson red blood which is
going to be an absolute ball ache to go
in the wash also he dies what really
stung was that poor old Caleb got
trapped in the complex during the escape
and she abandoned him without hesitation
just goes to prove that no matter how
much you love a machine it will never
love you back
Hal 9000 from 2001 a Space Odyssey was
obviously going to make this list not
just for murdering multiple people but
for ruining the song daisy bell' for
everyone Hal is the ship's computer
installed upon the discovery one
spacecraft designed to aid the career of
scientists on their mission to Jupiter
but just like the White Star Line said
that the Titanic was unsinkable how
states that he is foolproof and
incapable of error and if they aren't
red flags I don't know what are but also
the crew should have figured out
something wasn't quite right about how
because his voice is creepy as hell I'm
sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do that
but anyway putting all of your
cryogenically frozen eggs into the wonky
a ice basket
was of course only going to end in
disaster
after howl it reads a conversation the
scientists have about trying to
deactivate him shortly after all those
frozen scientists eggs get straight-up
scrambled and that's exactly why I
disconnected Siri so there we are
six robots that we definitely shouldn't
have trusted for more videos like this
make sure to LIKE and subscribe you
won't stop to gamespot subscribe to
GameSpot subscribe to GameSpot